[Music]
becoming a member of the European Union
is a complex process which doesn't
happen overnight a country needs to meet
strict but fair criteria for example a
functioning market economy to help it
compete within the European Union and
beyond but what is a market economy it
is an economy in which prices and
production are determined by buyers and
sellers freely conducting business
successful market economies call for
sound economic governance with
governments and independent actors like
central banks regulating and steering it
based on some economic fundamentals
these include macroeconomic stability a
welcoming business environment
functioning labor and financial markets
good levels and quality of education
infrastructure innovation and economic
integration with the EU and the world so
what is the European Union doing to help
since 2015
all EU candidate countries and potential
candidates prepare economic reform
programs these outline the medium-term
macro economic and fiscal framework as
well as structural reforms to enhance
competitiveness and long-term growth
once a year the European Commission and
the European Central Bank prepare their
assessment of the programmes this forms
the basis for the multilateral economic
policy dialogue involving enlargement
countries EU Member States the
Commission and European Central Bank the
dialogue culminates in a high-level
meeting during which participants adopt
joint conclusions on progress made by
each country and areas where more work
is still needed these conclusions are
then reflected in a fresh round of
economic reform programs which marks the
start of the next annual cycle this
process helps candidate countries and
potential candidates to get ready for
the European semester a mechanism used
to coordinate economic policies within
the European Union
you want to know more right
you